the hman segment number three Caleb
Williams now I'm gonna say that because
y'all just seen this game this coming up
weekend hey he's what they what they've
been wanting he's that guy he's off the
above I mean he go out there work hard I
can tell you work hard he know what the
read he know when to get out the pocket
he know when to stay in the pocket he he
just make good decisions and I mean
that's what you need at the quarterback
spot and number one come on
man there's only one choice and that's
me both sides of the ball I'm going for
it on like I said on Instagram H has
been loading that's my goal that's what
I'm reaching you got sometimes you got
to put your goals out there let
everybody know what you reaching I'm
just gonna do what I could do best this
year show everybody that me going
Jackson State and so-called not playing
in a good conference wasn't good for me
I'm going to show y'all I'm going show
the doubters and prove them wrong man we
got a lot to come this season